let me say quickly
because god must always be the focus i
have been honored to be here
i've been highly blessed i thank my
pastor
that's makua for inviting me i'm
grateful for the very great kindness of
pastor fred
pastor ultim all the others who
came in contact with me i will go away
with not
one complaint did you hear me
not one i thank god for the mokayah
family where i've been staying
god knows how i am and he arranged for
me the perfect setting
may god bless that family to high heaven
from this day forward until jesus comes
and may he save every member of that
family
while i'm saying that to them if there's
anyone online watching
and you've kept me in your home as i
have been on god's business
may the lord continue to bless you bless
your families
and admit your children ahead of you
into his kingdom
thank you brother charles thank you
sister leah thank you pauline who have
not yet met
thank you jackson have not yet met and
thank you my brother dr david wherever
he is
thank you thank you thank you for
opening your palace to me
you shall live in my heart and i will
pray for you as long
as i live i have some very special
little
friends who always come and check on me
i don't know where they are but they
come wherever i
am and they check on me uh sister elvira
she raised her hand right there where is
my little brother benjamin i don't know
where he is but benjamin keeps waving at
me every 10 seconds he says hi
i was chatting with maria i don't know
where she is where'd maria go
ah there's maria god bless the little
children who made my life so happy
i mean it god bless them and the bigger
children
and the bigger children and the adult
children thank you very much
for your affection i really mean that
and when i go i shall go with a heart
full of sweet sweet memories
like a bouquet of roses in my heart
every petal
is a lovely memory god bless you and do
everything you can to hold on to jesus
you know let me pray father in heaven
i'm just making these remarks you may
turn them into the sermon i'm not sure
but let the spirit speak through me
father and let me do everything in my
power to glorify you
in jesus name i pray amen
in first timothy chapter 6 verse 12 when
i'm leaving this with you
timothy paul told timothy fight
the good fight of faith you don't sit on
a couch and go to heaven
are you with me there's an adversary
there is an enemy
who puts up roadblocks and so paul tells
timothy fight the good fight of him
lay hold on eternal life in other words
don't just hold it like that
anyone can snap just out of your hand
hold it like this
then put it right here no one can get it
holy hold he said
on eternal life but we only lay hold on
that which we
value highly are you following me we
must value salvation
we must value jesus jesus is salvation
and so paul told timothy fight
the good fight of faith young man wrote
me he said pastor i'm caught up in
certain sin which will go unmentioned
and i wrote back i said listen
you have to fight because you're
fighting for your life
remember joseph not joseph jacob at
midnight
by that stream when someone touched him
on his shoulder what did he start to do
he started to fight you know he was
fighting with god
and he fought the bible says all night
then the person said let me go and jacob
said no because he realized who he was
struggling with
he was fighting for his life god touched
his hip
and dislocated the hip he kept fighting
on one foot
and for the rest of his life he limped
sometimes contact with god
leaves a physical mark to remind you who
gave it to you but he gave it to you for
your salvation
and i say to you fight the good fight of
faith
in uh galatians chapter 5 verse 17 for
the flesh
lusteth against the spirit and the
spirit against the flesh
and these are contrary one to the other
in other words paul is saying is a
constant battle constant battle
even in the converted person there is a
constant battle
and that battle will only end when this
mortal
puts on immortality and is corruptable
puts on in corruption and so
paul told timothy fight the good fight
of faith
james gives us some advice and james was
the half brother of jesus
in james chapter 4 verse 10 here's what
he tells us
submit yourself therefore to god
resist the devil and he
will flee
we need to see the devil running more
often not to us but away from us
james gives a step number one submit
yourself therefore to god
and that's a mission must be total
submit your profession to god submit
your children to god
submit your financial life to god submit
your home to god
submit your love life to god let the
submission be complete
without a complete submission god cannot
save you or me
and so james the half-brother of jesus
tells us
submit yourself therefore to god then he
says
resist the devil and he will flee the
word resist
is an action word resist it takes effort
you know i love going to the gym lifting
is my favorite exercise is something
called a deadlift
and i just love the deadlift man you've
got to make effort
you do three reps or 400 pounds and you
you have made an effort because you have
resist you have to resist something
called
inertia inertia is a tendency of an
object to stay where it is
are you with me you've got to say no no
no no i'm going to lift you
off the ground it takes your energy
and after three repetitions that's it
and you go sit down for
three minutes to catch your breath and
recover james tells
us resist the devil and
he will flee he'll take a vacation
now he'll come back let him flee again
and so we have fight the good fight of
faith
i used to work in a medical school many
years ago as a counselor
and i would counsel phd students they're
doing md phd
and md by itself is enough torture a phd
by itself and any science is torture
they're doing combined first years of
medicine next three years of phd
then back to medicine for two years take
about seven eight nine years
and they'd come to my office the
experiment didn't work
and they stay in the laboratory the lab
many many years
uh nights late nights not go home some
would sleep in the lab
because they were fighting that
experiment had to work
so they can get results and publish a
paper
and so they were fighting the good fight
of scientific research
they made a sacrifice some homes broke
up
all night in the library i saw couples
come to medical school they came married
left divorce
because they were each under so much
stress but the medical degree was
important to them
and so they put the effort they made the
sacrifice
it cost them the bible says
fight turn off that tv
get on social media for a while if
you're not conducting any worthwhile
ministry
make an effort and god will bless your
effort
with his power ella white writes in the
work of redemption
god requires the cooperation of man you
must work with god
for your salvation in revelation
john tells us behold i come quickly hold
that fast which thou hast
that no man take thy crown revelation 3
behold i come quickly this is christ
hold
that fast that no man
if you have a dog you give the dog a
bone have you ever tried taking the bone
out of the dog's mouth
that dog will start to growl because
you're messing with his livelihood are
you following me
the dog will hold if you have a pet lion
because none of you do but and you do
don't go close to the lion when you feed
him feed him from a distance
because the moment you throw that meat
that lion changes personality
and starts to growl and he protects that
meat
he does not want to share that meat with
another lion or a hyena or human being
this is his meat and so the bible tells
us behold i come quickly
hold that fast
hold on to what you have hold on to this
as christ forgiven you hold on to the
forgiveness by avoiding sin
has god blessed your life with some
insight in this word hold on to it
by studying it and living life
accordance with god has shown you
we have to learn to hold on
because there's a power opposing you
hold on look at the words again fight
the good fight of faith someone
wrote me and said uh i'm trying to
conquer this particular sin
uh it occurs when such and such comes
close to me this lady i
wrote back and said well tell the lady
don't come close to you
or stay away from her if her presence
contributes to your weakness
avoid her the way job avoided sin here
is how god described job in job chapter
1 verse 8 let me pray again
father in heaven speak through me very
clearly dear god
that your people may be blessed by your
word in jesus name i pray
amen and the lord said unto satan hast
thou
considered my servant job there is none
like him in the earth let me pause on
that isn't that a beautiful testimony
from god
about a human being there are some
testimonials god has given in the bible
that are so
beautiful and i covet them
when god spoke abraham he said i know
him
that he will command his children and
his household after him i
know that man i can trust him to lead
his family
and god told satan hast thou considered
my servant job
there is none like him in the earth
and this is god testifying to the
character
of job or that god will say that about
me
when god looks down on minnesota
minneapolis or
champlain or brooklyn park or winning
tonka or is it minnetonka
or ramsay let him say have you ever seen
the ramsest dear church
there is no church like that church have
you seen kcc
you seen this young man
there is no young man like him i can
turn my back
and i know he's not embarrassing me
there's none like him there's none like
him in the earth
a perfect and an upright man one that
feareth god
and esther with evil the fancy word s2
means to avoid
and so i told this young man avoid the
person
who endangers your spiritual life
this other young fellow wrote me as i
broke up with this girl but we're still
in touch and there we fight i said look
jesus said if your right hand offends
you do what two things what are the two
things
cut it off come on cast it from you
this is no joke it off
and then throw it away
if you're in a relationship that has
intentioned your spiritual life
cut it off
somebody say amen and leave it cut off
and then toss it away i have spoken to
so many young people who are in mixed
relationships adventists not adventists
i said look break it off
tonight you call him i'll talk to him
for you
i was in mombasa doing a
camp meeting i was counseling this young
lady came to me uh maybe 28 27.
i have a boyfriend he's not adventist
i said you got to break it off i don't
need details is the adventist no break
it off don't give me a speech
break it off we've been together three
years we're three years late in breaking
it off
i said she said how can i do that i said
call him i'll talk to him
so she called him and he came to the
campground and he stood right
there she stood right there and i spoke
to him listen to what i told him
shook his hand says nice to meet you
you're a handsome young man
she has made a mistake and deceived you
she has caused you to believe that this
church
favors this kind of relationship and it
does not she's wrong
you did nothing right all you did was
exercise good taste
and he shook my hand he said pastor i
understand
i prayed and he left and they never got
back together again
are you following me anything that
endangers
your eternal life cut it off and
cast it from you if you are in that
situation right now with that guilty
smile on your face
break it off call the pastor the elder
come with me
and go announce i was wrong i was at a
church in a certain city new york
preaching this young lady came to me
pray for my boyfriend
i said uh why he won't come to church
i said but why wouldn't your boyfriend a
nice faithful vegetarian adventist
not come to church and she said
he's not an adventist i said oh okay
here's what i'll pray for i will pray
that you will apologize to god
for misleading him into thinking this is
okay
she turned away and walked away
anything that endangers your eternal
life
get rid of it not your husband of course
or your wife but
anything else get rid of it are you with
me
come on say a man all right what words
have we looked at
fight the good fight of faith where's
that text found i told you
come on come on we haven't got all day
where's the text found
first timothy 6 12.
paul said fight and timothy was a as a
matter of fact
timothy was a teenager when paul called
him to work
young men don't wait until you're 28
serve god at 14
13 12 16. don't just spend your life
playing video games and watching
basketball
god needs your energy and your youth
and so we're to fight the good fight of
faith what was the next word we talked
about
resist where is that text found
not genesis no james yes what chapter
what verse seven but what's the word
that comes before
resist submit yourself to god
resist the devil and he will flee from
you now
here's something else go to john 15 john
15.
john 15 god bless you for loving god for
loving his word
and i address these remarks to you in
this building and to god's people
watching via the internet thank you very
much
for joining night after night day after
day i really mean it
it was my honor to bring god's word to
you john 15
reading from verse 1 jesus speaking let
me pray father please
restrain me and let your spirit have his
way in jesus name i plead and
implore amen i am the true vine
and my father is the husband man every
branch in
me that beareth not fruit he taketh away
by the way i think i've said this before
it is the father that gets rid of
useless branches
so when you decide to leave the church
because you were badly treated
no one could get you to leave the church
if you truly love christ are you with me
no one can get you to leave the church
you can join another church of the same
congregate same denomination
but no one can get you to leave jesus
unless you choose to leave jesus
jesus said every branch in me that
beareth not fruit he taketh away
and every branch that beareth through he
purges it that it may
bring forth more fruit now read verse 3
of john 15. come on if you have the king
james version nice and loud
now ye are clean how
through the word come on did i wish i
have spoken unto you
now we have resist we have fight we have
hold on
and we have the word
nothing will cleanse your mind
like the word not a course in psychology
from the university of champlain
but the word of god will cleanse
your mind it is a cleansing agent and so
jesus told the disciples ye are clean
through the word which i have spoken
unto you
how does god cleanse the church
ephesians 5 let's read from verse 25
ephesians 5 reading from verse 25.
i should have told you i read from the
king james version
of the bible do you have ephesians 5
reading verse 25
listen and read microscopically are you
there
husbands love your wives all husbands
amen
that was weak but that's okay husbands
love your wives
even as christ also loved the church and
gave himself for it
that he might sanctify and cleanse it
now you read for me
with the washing of
by the word the washing of water by the
word
so he cleanses the church through the
the word has a cleansing effect on the
mind
go to psalm 119 let's read verse 9
every young person should know this
verse from memory very short
very powerful psalm 119 verse 9 it says
this
wherewithal shall a young man cleanse
his ways
by taking he there thereto according to
thy word
the bible is saying how can a young man
clean up his life
it's very sad that the young life has to
be cleaned up but that's the case in
which the
world in which we live the bible says by
taking he thereto
according to thy word young man young
woman old man old woman it is the same
the word of god is the cleansing agent
christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
one
ellen white writes if studied and
obeyed you know that's my favorite word
the word of god
works in the heart subduing
every unholy attribute
now think of those words if studied
and obeyed someone wrote me
very early this year my spiritual life
is declining
i have no interest in spiritual things
church reading praying
i know god is good i love him but i just
have lost interest
i sent her bible passage to read and
analyze
and answer questions for me i told her i
said pray
read the passage several times when you
read
shut out every possible distraction so
just you and that word existing in the
universe you and that word nothing else
exists
read it then read it again then read it
five times
minimum ask the spirit of god just
direct your thinking
then answer this question she wrote back
i am revived
send me more studies so girl you study
for yourself
i am revived she said this is amazing
the word of god is designed to revive
you
it's designed to clean you up and so the
servant of god says
if studied and obeyed
the word of god works in the heart
subduing every unholy
attribute jesus was praying to his
father
and he said sanctify them
through thy truth finish the verse thy
word
is truth now jesus told the father
sanctify his disciples
we know from first thessalonians chapter
4 3 and
this is the will of god even your
sanctification
if the will of god is our sanctification
and first john 5 14 says if we ask
anything according to his will
he heareth us and if jesus prayed that
prayer
anything jesus prays the father answered
then we have a prayer from jesus
for our sanctification
he said do it through the word i'll tell
you something else go to john 17.
let's read verse 9. john 17
verse 9 if this does not make you feel
good i don't know what will
john 17 reading verse 9.
let's read from verse 8 then we go to 9.
john 17 8 and 9.
then we go to 20 2
20 20 after we go 8-9 for i have given
unto them the words which thou gavest me
and they have received them and have
known surely that i came out from thee
and they have believed that thou they
send me now verse nine very carefully
i pray for them
i pray not for the world
stop jesus says
i am praying for them
the disciples you know at that moment
he's not praying for the world
i pray for them i pray not for the world
but for them which that has given me for
their thine and all
mine are thine and thy in the mind jesus
said i prayed for them now you may say
yes but
that was 2000 years ago go to verse 20.
now if you have the king james version
you read it out loud for me what does
this say
neither pray i for these
come on but for them also we shall
believe on me
so jesus is saying all those who accept
the gospel down to the ages
this prayer covers them
do you understand what this means to you
jesus
prayed for you ah that amen is weak
i said jesus prayed for you now your
mother has prayed for you god bless her
my mother prayed for me all the days of
her life since i was born
and i credit god first for my spiritual
position and my mother my mother
she's resting in her grave but my mother
she prayed for her children and i thank
god for that
and if my mother and i come to the
heavenly gates and there's one space
left
give it to her without hesitation
jesus prayed for you remember when
jesus said to peter simon simon satan
hath desired to have you
that he may sift you as wheat what are
the next few words jesus says
but i come on have prayed for thee that
thy faith fail not
wait a minute
jesus prayed for peter
that prayer is for us you're saying amen
because you're nice
but do you understand what you're saying
amen for
who is jesus he's god
what did he do he created heaven and
earth
by his word what else did he do he died
on calvary
he is god he is creator
he's always been there he conquered
death
he raised himself from the grave he
told peter i
have prayed for you
that thy faith fail not question for you
if jesus prayed that prayer to the
father for peter
will the father answer that prayer yes
now
john 17 20 neither pray i for these
alone
but for them also we shall believe on me
through the word
jesus prayed for you do not disappoint
his prayer
right where you sit you are covered by
the prayer
of your savior he cannot force you you
can choose by your lifestyle or i can't
but by ins and step away from the
covering of that prayer
but if you and i will hold on to jesus
that
prayer he offered in john 17 will
continue
to cover us
fight the good fight of faith
submit yourself to god resist the devil
avoid circumstances that put your
salvation in peril
this is the cleansing agent
and jesus offered a prayer for you
i pray for them i pray not for the world
my brothers and sisters how could you
lose with the word of god on your side
how can you lose with jesus praying for
you
how can you lose with a father who
answers any prayer
that jesus offered when jesus prays
father
spirit and son are all on your side
we have the resources to conquer
we have what is required to live a life
that glorifies god
and embarrasses the devil
other thing you need to understand let's
look at the very
first promise of the bible the first
genesis 3 verse 15 you should say it
without looking
but i'll be merciful genesis 3 verse
15 let me pray again father
i'm soon to end my remarks continue to
speak through me god
and bless your lovely people gathered in
this building and on the internet in
jesus name i pray
amen genesis 3 15 and i
will put enmity between thee and the
woman between thy seed and her seed it
shall bruise thy head
and thou shalt bruise his heel listen to
that verse microscopically
i that's god we'll put hatred in you
for the things of the devil
you know why god has to do that and i
told you that a few weeks a few days ago
because of adam we are born with enmity
toward god
god says wait a minute i need to switch
that enmity around
i will put enmity in you for the things
of the devil
and the opposite effect will be you will
have love
for me ask god
to give you hatred for gambling
if that's your weakness ask god say
father
you said always confront the confront is
not a good word
always present god's word to him for
instance if well let me continue with
this
ask god to take selfishness out of your
heart
all of this are expressions of enmity
against god
ask him take out of me selfishness
laziness this constant avoiding of god's
word
take it out of me and replace it
with the love for god a love for his
word a love for prayer
a love for witnessing a love for
kindness
a love for generosity the very
first promise of the bible
is a promise from god to put hatred in
the heart
for the things of the devil when you
pray i was saying
present god with this word for instance
let's say one of your children left the
church
you pray to god you go to second peter
chapter three verse nine
the lord is not slack concerning his
promise as some men count slackness
but is long suffering to us word not
willing that
any should perish if your son's name is
john and he left the church
father you said you're not willing
that john should perish if you mean it
do everything necessary to bring him
back
not for my sake but for your sake
because you're not willing
that john should perish father my
husband loves me
he's very nice but he needs to
understand the truth
you say father you said in first timothy
chapter two verse four
you will have all men to be saved and to
come
unto the knowledge of the truth if you
want him to know the truth
reveal it to him i pray remind god
of what he said you say father you said
bring all the tithe into the storehouse
that there may be meat in mine house
and prove me now here with save the lord
of hosts
if i will not open you the windows of
heaven
do you understand what open you the
windows of heaven mean go to genesis 7
let me show you what that means
genesis 7 we're talking about using
god's word when you pray
god may ignore your words he will never
ignore his
genesis 7 reading verse 11.
in the 600 year of noah's life
in the second month the 17th day of the
month
the same they were all the founders of
the great deep broken up finish the
verse
and the windows of heaven what
what came down the flood
you see when god made the earth he
separated water
here was the earth there was water on
the earth in the earth and above the
earth
and so the earth was in a sort of a
greenhouse arrangement you understand
to protect the earth from the harmful
rays coming in from space
they're harmful to us but they have
their function in god's system let me
say it again
if you read don't go there just listen
ii peter 3 5 for
this they willingly are ignorant of that
by the word of god
the heavens were of old and the earth
standing out of the water
and in the water there's water under the
earth
there's water on the earth and there's
there was water above the earth
when god sent the flood he brought down
he brought up water from underneath
he brought down water from above so much
the bible says
the highest mountains were covered now
the highest mountains keep this image in
mind and listen to
malachi 310 bring me all the tithe into
the storehouse
that there may be meat in my house and
prove me now here with saved lord of
hosts
if i will not open you the windows of
heaven
and pour you out a blessing
they shall not be rude enough to receive
it the same with that flood
covered every mountaintop when god
blesses
the faithful tithe giver or tithe
returner
god will bless you to cover every need
you have somebody say amen
i didn't say every luxury you desire i
said every need you have
god will cover it because he said so
and covered 19 does not change the word
of god
are you following me god's promises are
sure
regardless of sociological conditions
and so when you pray to god
you say you said
that's what you said now if i had said
it father i understand
but you said and your word in titus 1
says which god that
cannot lie your word says in numbers 23
19 god is not a man that he shall lie
you said
now stand by your word of course you say
that with respect
and watch what god but god will also say
but you also said i will follow thee my
save you said that
what happened to that you said that what
happened to that
you said give me the bible you said that
what happened to that you're so busy
with work in school and children and
boyfriends
you have no time for that which gives
you life let me tell you something and
i'll stop
let me pray again father i'll close
give me a straight message for your
people please father and restrain my
carnal nature
in jesus name amen
how many of you have ever sent up a
prayer request to god can i see your
hand
or give you want to pastor yes do you
know god has prayer requests
we're always giving prayer requests to
people pray for this pray for that
and i travel all over the world by god's
grace and i get sheets of prayer
requests
and i pray for all of them god has
prayer requests
but nobody asks him what his prayer
requests are here's a prayer request
from god
pray every morning
and every night at least god said listen
world i have another prayer requests
give me my tithe that's god
and god is on his knees for years
praying please give me my tithe
and stop hurting yourself stop living on
the curse
god has prayer requests gather your
children every day
and have family worship even if you get
to work late
that's god's prayer request god has
another prayer request
stop fighting among yourselves because
it's a bad example of the community
god has prayer requests let's answer his
god has prayer requests stop drinking
alcohol secretly
stop smoking secretly
stop living your life on the internet on
sites that are dirty and nasty and
impure
that's god's prayer request now let's
grant
god's prayer requests
young man god has a prayer request for
you since that young lady became your
girlfriend
is she closer to god or further from god
is she closer to her parents
or always fighting her parents is she at
risk being your girlfriend
god has a prayer request have the right
influence on my daughter
what did i say fight the good fight of
faith
what else did i say resist but before
resist
submit resist what did i say about the
word
it cleanses what did i say about
something that's an offense to you
cut it off and throw it away throw it so
far
it never comes back like azzazeel on the
day of atonement
what else did i say when you pray to god
do what
present god with his word
with his word you said you
said you said and god will
never back away from his word
but listen now when god says now here's
what i want you to do
a relationship is not a one-way street
goes two ways god said okay send your
request to me how many do you have two
million okay fine i only have three
pray study the word
and wrap that all into one word obey me
let me close by telling you this the
person
who obeys god will incur
no regrets
the world may think you're suffering let
me say it again
the person who commits his or her life
to obey god from the heart will
incur no regrets there are no
regrets for serving god
young people you're 17 18
if jesus doesn't come you get to 30 and
40 the quality of your life then
will depend on the decisions and choices
you make now
put your life in the life in the hand of
god
he'll take care of it and you look back
and you may see no regrets or very few
and the ones you have will be small
because god knows how to manage the life
and so as i leave you i call upon you in
the name of jesus
in the name of jesus
live your life for the glory of god
there is a bible verse we tend to take a
symbolic it's not
whether therefore he eat
or drink come on finish it or whatsoever
he do finish the verse do all
which means let me ask you this if you
do something directly for god's glory
is that a spiritual act yes
some of you didn't get it let me ask
again if you do something
chiefly for the glory of god is that a
spiritual act
the answer is yes now
the bible says do everything
for the glory of god then our lives
should be one constant spiritual life
when you work listen to ephesians 6 5
servants be obedient to them that are
your masters
according to the flesh with fear and
trembling
in singleness of your heart as unto
christ
work as if you're working for christ
is that a spiritual act yes
if your work is to repave the highway
the bible says whatsoever thy hand
findeth to do finish it for me do it
with thy might
that's a spiritual which means
excellence is spiritual behavior
ah come on say amen excellence
is spiritual behavior young men young
women you want to be spiritual in the
classroom
pursue excellence
it is not an act it's a state of mind
in psalm 106 verse 3 blessed are they
that keep judgment
and he that doeth righteousness at
all times
and there's something i love to tell
god's people you've probably heard it
before
what time is it can someone tell me the
time what time is it if someone has a
watch
a clock what time is it
6 21 6 25 somewhere around 6 25 when
does the sun set
eight all right when what what was that
whenever it says it's all right when the
sun
sets listen to me carefully what comes
to an end
the sabbath the holy day in the bible
a day begins at sunset when the listen
to me carefully
when the sun sets the sabbath the holy
day
is over but you
are still a holy person
the sun does not set on your holiness
so whatever plans you have for tonight
when the sun sets
now that you know it does not set on
your holiness
you may have to change them somebody say
amen you may have to change them
because you're required to be holy how
many days of the week
how many hours case closed
that's living consciously
blessed are they that do righteousness
at all
times first timothy chapter 4 verse 8
but bodily exercise profiteth little
but godliness is profitable
unto all things having promise of the
life that now is
and of the life to come
godliness righteousness right doing
has benefits now and the benefits extend
into the life to come
i'm gonna close don't panic but you need
to understand this
when jesus comes a curtain does not come
down on your life
and then you start a new life you start
a new life physically
you don't start a new life morally
the very first day we spend in heaven
will be no different
from the last day we spend on earth
let me say differently we must live as
if we're in heaven now
before we actually get there is that
clear now we must live
now and so i say again when christ comes
he does not bring down a curtain and
said okay this life is over
and this one starts the curtain does not
come down on the character
we move into heaven with the same
character
we had when jesus came down the skies
we have to live it now
this is the power let me speak to anyone
of any age
make an effort to memorize some verses
make an effort i have a friend in
kenya god bless kenny all the kenyans
kenya she's a grandmother
very precious friend of mine i won't
call her name i know she's listening
lovely family ah the family lives right
here
my heart is full of family and still
room for more
and i told her why don't you try
memorizing some verses
she was hesitant i believe at first now
she's
she once did the first 10 chapters of
proverbs can you ima
now it's it's memorizing proverbs is a
challenge because each verse is almost
different from the other
are you following me i mean you memorize
daniel chapter two
there's a story but proverbs every verse
seems to be independent so it's a real
challenge but she went through the first
10 chapters
and then john this and john that and
she's been memorizing i have another
friend in kenya
i said why don't you memorize some
verses person started
john 14 then john this and then john
that
and then first john and i said listen
these chapters are fine why don't you
memorize a book
memorize the book of jonah
you have a mind that was designed
to study god's word and memorize it now
will it be a challenge at first
yes we have a saying practice makes
perfect
have you heard that saying yes that's
how professional football players are so
good at basketball or baseball or
football or
hockey or whatever now in mind
character and personality volume 2 page
601 paragraph 4 ella white writes
that which at first seems difficult by
constant repetition grows easy
i want you to memorize the bible first
right now it'll take you five seconds or
less
fewer are you ready first thessalonians
5 17
pray without ceasing say back to me
you just memorized the verse now if you
can memorize
that three words
then find a verse that has four words
are you following
let's memorize another verse john 11 35
jesus wept
make a tremendous effort and say back to
me
you just had another verse you strained
your brain and you said it
jesus swept three words let's try a
longer one
prove all things hold fast that which is
good let me hear it
yes try
you'll be excited and the presence of
the word
in your head will assist you
in dealing with spiritual challenges if
you read
the sermon on the day of pentecost in
acts chapter 2
one third of that sermon is old
testament quotations
peter did not have a bible
you read all the sermons in the book of
acts peter paul
james whomever they all have old
testament quotations they did not
carry bibles they were not bibles to
carry back then if there's a scroll
it's in the synagogue remember luke 4 16
and jesus as his custom was went up into
the synagogue
and sat down and he was lived unto him
to scroll
and he read that's what the bible was
you better thank god everyone has a
bible today even though it's not read
make an effort and i recommend to you
the book of john because john tells us
he wrote that book
so that those who read it will have
eternal life
and he was the closest disciple to jesus
he lived the longest and ella white says
of all the disciples
he was the one who most closely
reflected the character of jesus read
the gospel of john
that's where john 3 16 is say john 3 16
for me
god bless you forever put the word of
god in your heart teach it
to your children teach it
now who can give me all 66 books from
genesis to revelation
in order all 66.
don't raise your hands all together at
the same time who can
oh come yes come come come
come all 66 then i'll pray teach the
children you'll be surprised how quickly
they learn
they will learn these things but don't
tell them go and learn it
you teach them so you are involved come
how are you you look like a nice boy
what's your what's your name
wesley wesley's a good name how old are
you 10.
jesus was 10. he was a good boy
are you a good boy say yes yes
wesley genesis of revelation here you go
genesis exodus leviticus numbers
jude ruth deuteronomy
joshua numbers
[Music]
job sam's
proverbs ecclesiastics
songs of solomon isaac
isaiah
jeremiah limitation
ezekiel daniel
hosea joe
thank you
[Music]
matthew mark luke and john acts romans
limitations easy
[Music]
thessalonians 2 thessalonians
first john first timothy 2 timothy
titus fiolina
hebrews james first peter
ii peter first john
ii john third john
jude revelation
thank you professor okay god bless you
let me tell you a little secret it is
one thing to note when you're sitting in
the pew
it is something altogether different to
come and stand here
i mean everything goes off your head and
flies to heaven and so god bless my
young brother god bless him
how many of you will say lord i recommit
my life to you
hold me and guide me can i see your
right hand
stand with me
before i pray i'm gonna invite you to
give me prayer requests
not little sermons just pray requests
are you with me make them short and to
the point
this side any prayer requests just raise
your hand and tell me
what's her name nicole how old is she
oh okay yes my young brother
yes okay all right anybody else yes
sister
pray for your children to come to christ
when you speak lower your mask
anybody else on this side no no no no
yes sister
[Music]
your children to accept christ okay
children are precious
isaiah 49 25 i will save thy children
this side oh yes my little sister
pray for everyone who's sick okay yes
we'll do that yes
pray for whom oh yes thank you very much
yes yes anybody else
yes my brother okay my sister
your brothers
your friend's baby
oh no jesus was a baby god has a special
place in his heart for babies okay yes
my brother
your brother's drinking okay
he used to preach he can come back and
preach
he can come back solomon walked with god
then he left
then he came back yes sister oh yes go
ahead
you know what
freedom of oh yes it won't last forever
yes
okay yes sister
yoho pray for your sister
pray for whom her sister
and mother
oh the sister's name is martha
okay all right thank you yes did i see
your hand no
yes
okay all right okay yes sister
your brother your children
speak loudly your family okay yes my
young brother
okay what's his name
julian okay all right
anybody else yes my brother
for whom
oh yes yes yes yes yes yes my brother
lower that mask
your family all right yes yes sister
the orphans oh yes yes orphans
yes
your friends carmen who came that the
spirit will continue to work on her
heart yes we're in the back
yes yes to hold on the devil will try to
discourage you
hold on and you hold on by holding on to
this by faith
because jesus is the word all right
anything else
all right let us kneel and i'll pray
father in heaven we come before you
in the name of jesus jesus said if he
shall ask anything
in my name i will do it
but he also says if he abide in me
and my words abide in you you shall ask
what he will
and it shall be done unto you
his word also says and whatever we ask
we receive of him
because we keep his commandments and do
those things which are right in his
sight
his word also says whosoever shall turn
away his ear from hearing the law
even his prayer shall be an abomination
his word also says if i regard iniquity
in my heart
the lord will not hear me
now father we kneel before you we come
before you in the name of sinless
jesus the one who said
let there be light the one who said at
the tomb of lazarus i am
the resurrection and the life the one
who said on the cross
it is finished the one who said at the
open grave oh death where is thy sting
oh grave where is thy victory the one
who said
i will come again and receive you unto
myself
in his name we come to you father
if we have misrepresented you today
on the strength of the sacrifice of
jesus
forgive us with the removal of sin
replace it with a hatred for sin which
is to say a
love for jesus and what he will have us
to do
may god change our hearts i pray
because everything proceeds from the
heart
change our hearts give us a new one and
a new spirit
we recommit our lives to your loving
father we're so sorry for the many times
we've disappointed you we recommit our
lives regardless of
age they got we recommit our lives to
you now
and we ask you father to pay attention
to all the prayer requests that were
mentioned you heard them
you knew them before they were spoken
their prayers for children to come to
christ
for those who are sick for unity in the
church